[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and a busy news
night tonight by a vote of 255 to 67
Obama's Attorney General Eric hold was
found in contempt to Congress he served
no jail time well corrupt leftwing IRS
director remember Lois learner found in
contempt of congress also zero days in
jail Hunter Biden he refused to comply
with an initial house ofena and sent
lawmakers on a wild goose chase taunting
them every step of the way Hunter Biden
will face no jail time for contempt of
congress and is now complying a after
asking for a brand new subpoena and by
the way naturally two former Trump
advisers not so lucky I wonder why Joe
Biden's Department of Justice is now
trying to lock up both Steve Bannon and
Peter Navaro in fact Navaro was only
sentenced to four months in prison uh
this week and Peter Navaro will join us
and first tell a story exclus
exclusively here tonight but first
breaking tonight as reported by our very
own bill maluan quote in Friday news
dump Customs and Border Patrol officials
report
32,34 migrant which would be illegal
immigrant Encounters in December the
highest month ever recorded and CBP also
reports that border patrol arrested 19
more people on the FBI terrorist watch
list in December bringing the total to
50 arrests for the fiscal year 2024 so
far and as John Solomon uh first
reported right here on this program last
night high ranking former FBI officials
are now calling the crisis at our
Southern border an alarming and perilous
invasion of military AED male foreigners
who posed one of the most pernicious uh
ever threats to American Security and
now the showdown at the Texas border it
is escalating that thanks to your
president why Joe Biden issued a
deadline of today demanding that Texas
allow Federal officials access to Shelby
Park this is at Eagles pass and illegal
immigration hotspot on the border that
was seized by Texas officials in other
words Biden painted himself into a
corner now because breaking tonight
Texas they're not going to comply so
what's Joe Biden going to do now is he
going to try and federalize the Texas
guard as some Democrats are recommending
is he going to try to arrest the
governor of Texas Greg Abbott uh will he
order a physical confrontation between
Texas security officials uh are you
serious this is a huge crisis Joe Biden
has now been put has put them in a
position where he's pitting law
enforcement versus law enforcement but a
senior border patrol official to their
credit telling Fox News border security
agents have zero plans to remove razor
wire or or impede Texas from securing
their border he emphasized that his
agency's relationship with Texas is
strong Rank and file Customs and Border
Patrol agents also reportedly respect
and appreciate what Texas is doing and
meanwhile Texas governor Abbott is now
offering cash payments to law
enforcement Personnel that volunteer to
man The Border Florida Governor Ronda
santis is working on a measure to send
the Florida state guard to Texas to help
out South Dakota governor Christy gome
is vowing to ship razor wire and send in
that State's national guard Virginia
they've already deployed a 100 soldiers
and Airmen Arkansas and Nebraska have
also previously dep deployed members of
their National Guard and are vowing to
send more in the future North Dakota
governor bergam well he sent 125
soldiers from the 817th engineer company
more and more States now are stepping up
to the plate to fill pH a void left by
Joe Biden's dereliction of Duty he's not
fulfilling his oath to our constitution
his oath of office uh he's not enforcing
the laws of the land not only that he's
aiding and abetting and the lawbreaking
it is now more uh than ever obvious that
either Joe Biden is the single most
incompetent person to have ever stepped
foot in the Oval Office or he's just
perpetuating the Border crisis on
purpose to be honest it's probably a
mixture of both ask yourself why is Joe
Biden willing to set deadlines and
possibly even use Force against the
state of Texas and Texas National Guard
but let's see he cowers in fear when it
comes to Iran and China and Russia and
the hoodi rebels in Yemen why does Biden
seem to hate fellow Americans more than
the terrorists that want to kill us
overseas or maybe some that got into our
country with the nearly 10 million
illegal unve Joe Biden uh immigrants hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else